foreign
you know
life
foreign
[Music]
let's go let's go out of school
all right let's go
okay
so welcome everybody to Pi data Zoo
address
number 24. Friday the Heidelberg 2011.
uh it's great to see so many here
because we were not really sure about
how it's August so you want to go to the
swimming pool or go to meet up so uh
we're also streaming live on YouTube
that's why there will be some
information for the
people viewing at YouTube about where I
say we actually are so actually Pi
data's address is located here we are in
Heidelberg and if you don't know where
Heidelberg is because there's also
Heidelberg University I found out in uh
in the states
um but we're actually in the original
Heidelberg town with the original Castle
the location is down here in Germany why
do I push this a little bit more to an
international audience uh abroad because
everywhere I go to a conference people
ask me oh you're from Germany are you
from Berlin I said no I'm not from
Berlin Berlin is over here and let me
show you where the most important
universities in Germany are and the
Excellence like the elite universities
are also like located here and also like
um yeah the important companies of
Germany also like this is the actual
distribution so Germany is is different
not everything is in the capital as in
many other countries so I think it's
good to point this out a little bit more
so
um
so we are actually here working here too
much Geographics here so this is
Heidelberg again so we are here in
paretos is hosting us today startup in
Heidelberg we are at Palo Alto Platz
which is also no coincidence because
Alto is the uh is the uh what's it
called Partners city of Heidelberg
actually
um and
enough for that so um it's very
important always to be we are welcoming
uh Community we want to see who's around
for the first time so please raise your
hand if you're join this Meetup the
first time so or not I mean yeah like
this okay well like it's always like 50
it's always great to see so it's but
it's also really good for you to know
you're not the only new person here so
this is very welcoming community so if
you want to talk to people just like
start chatting so yeah welcome and I
want to tell you a little bit more about
what is pi data about
um Pi data is uh is was founded by num
focused and focus is a us-based
foundation that supports open source
software so many packages you use like
pandas or numpy or Jupiter are actually
also supported and co-funded by
non-focus and non-focus one day I've had
the idea to hey let's do PI data
actually the idea was uh quite a long
time ago so actually the first Pi data
conference was almost 10 years ago so
it's early yeah so there's next big
celebration next year probably in Berlin
we'll see
um
and
it's it's it's it's very important for
us to be a very welcoming um community
so there's a Code of Conduct
um so we don't tolerate any harassment
in the community members in in any form
um please feel free to go uh to the non
Focus website to read the full code of
conduct and if you ever have an
encounter anything please contact talk
to or organizers me Kevin
um and and and or you can also like do a
final report over the website it's very
important that everybody feels welcome
and this is uh and we have a healthy
community and yeah friendly for all so a
bit a bit more
um about this Meetup or like meet up the
pi data Meetup in general the pi data
Meetup actually has
a lot of chapters there's in total 221
groups now in the world
um they're in 76 countries with more
than 200 000 members so it's still
growing so and you're a part of that as
well
um also it's very important that's why
we also decided hey let's take an extra
hassle uh record the talks uh um and
stream it on YouTube for us especially
for the conferences it's important to
share the knowledge which is presented
and at the conference with the world and
actually there's now more than 3 000
videos with 150 000 subscribers on
YouTube which is yeah we only have 12
and a half thousand million views well I
mean we're in each topic we're not
Gangnam Style or
something like that but if you say like
it's like yes it's a funny topic still
like it's which which we're not pop
music it's not like that I think it's
pretty solid and also like about this
Meetup ideas actually we missed our
birthday in in March uh so actually it
was founded five years ago with the
pandas documentation Sprint
um and we were actually like two people
at this Meetup so I think we have grown
a bit in the past and uh and and it the
the meet up actually was uh we founded
it after we had the con pycon de the
German python conference which had a pi
data Dragon Castle and we said hey we're
all like a lot into data and so let's do
a local Pi data on chapter and there
were people from karsru from Heidelberg
and Mannheim and we said hi it's a
little bit ridiculous if we have like
three chapters here so let's let's
combine this because the the area is
closely connected
um so uh yeah so we actually like uh
1550 members now
um so
um please ping us if you want to host us
or you can also like Ping you like talk
to your company if you're interested in
hosting we're always looking for for
hosts like this like hey you have a nice
venue or something and people can gather
and we can have I can present talks and
the community can meet it's also very
important communities always give and
take so we love if you also step up and
say hey I have a proposal for a talk and
you can just also like submit this via
form
um on the link here or you can also just
start easy with the lightning talk so
I'm really happy so we have like free
lightning talks today already and we
have the first one for the next Meetup
already as well so things get going
um all this wouldn't be possible with
sponsors so today I'm very grateful that
parietos is sponsoring us for providing
the venue the food and everything
couldn't expect my company we are all
supporting the event organization from
the from the very beginning and of
course for them Focus for promoting open
source and I would like to introduce you
to Fabian he's the CTO of vampiritos I
will just join like this
yeah hello and nice to meet you nice to
see a lot of new faces as well happy to
meet as I said before feel like home
today drinks are in the fridge and
looking forward for some nice talks and
good conversations in general why we
Host this Meetup I mean I have two
slides about our company but actually
that doesn't matter too much because
while we Host this Meetup is because we
think that in this area there are a lot
of Brilliant Minds we have good
universities in all of the three cities
that you mentioned
and it's all about bringing things
together because I think we can build
something big out of here and uh
I believe in swarm intelligence and
people connecting from different
experiences why data science project
failed and so on so that's why we push
this and hopefully yeah grow together as
a community even stronger so thanks Alex
again for organizing thank you a little
Applause
and
perhaps just super brief what motivate
us as pie does is there's so much Excel
out there and this sucks I think there
could be a much better solutions for a
lot of problems but
we I think I can speak for all of us in
this room it is not only technology I
mean a lot of the papers were written 50
years ago but somehow still people
use Excel or gut feeding it's also about
how to connect and how to build
Solutions how to listen to people in
order to use the things because these
are often not data scientists that do
the decision at the end and we try to
yeah do our little part in it to build
this bridge when it comes to we have
technology and how do we make it
applicable especially in supply chain
areas but again I think Robert will give
some more insights later about the
interesting data science part and I keep
it for for this like now I think after
the Break
um there would be some good pizza
actually all pizza stores are on
vacation in Italy except of one so that
was the only bad thing that we didn't
include in our future covariates but we
made it we found one last pizza store
and looking forward
thank you thank you
all right
probably many of you know I'm Alex so
I'm partner at clinix week we
specialized in data engineering and data
strategy and we're always looking for
bright Minds so if you feel joining the
team or if you just want to chat just
come by and
let's talk so um we need a little bit
more support from you as well because we
uh thought about Meetup is a little bit
slow what's a little bit slow and it's
really hard to connect and we were
thinking about oh should we do our own
Discord and that's another Silo chat so
what the idea was let's let's do a
LinkedIn Group which was founded um just
a few months like two months ago um and
just join in and you can also help like
invite other people you think they are
really interested in so the um for us
it's very important it's a moderated
spam free environment so I'm really
really cautious not having like tons of
Recruiters in there or like people who
just like yeah just share noise all the
time because it's uh yeah other stuff so
it's it's it's it's it's important we
have we keep this healthy but of course
um who knows life hacketization
yeah okay who knows the telephone Lavina
so yeah basically yeah it's really easy
yeah if everybody just invites to
friends and there's two more friends and
then we can make we can basically reach
everybody who's also here
um in in our area we are new channels
because I know we haven't reached many
people like especially in institutes
there's been tons of people using Python
and they never heard about us because
they are use different channels than
this so stuff to do so
um that said you know finish with the uh
welcome uh so I would like to uh
announce uh the agenda so uh we start
with romance talk first then we have a
pizza break and then uh there's a talk
from Leon coming after that we have
lightning talks and networking and the
end and and you see on the talks and the
lightning talks we will live stream
um not the networking and the pizza
that's impossible
um
I'm happy to announce free lightning
talks today so we have uh through
lightning talks we have vetront who
talks about uh locating the spiral arms
of the Milky Way with decents
yeah
yeah that's you hello yes welcome oh
first time first time attendee and the
lightning talk wow welcome that's cool
that's cool
so then we have Bernard who I've seen
Bernard there's a second lightning talk
yeah developing ai's business analysts
data analysts using open AI function
calling and we have Tim from uh open oh
Tim here for more open source science
all right okay uh without further no one
more thing Community announcements
so who likes barbecue
Okay so
so where do you would think the big
pilot of Barbeque many of you know here
already anyway so uh yeah so the big
part in a barbecue menu would assume uh
to have this in Texas it was my pleasure
to do this like this this presentation
in Austin Texas at scipy because
everybody in Texas yeah barbecues Texas
and so now it's actually here in in
Heidelberg uh so yeah you see if you
have noticed also like from people who
watch the stream okay here's the castle
again we just have a different angle and
the barbecue is actually uh at the
mathematicon which is the faculty for
mathematics in Heidelberg and I'm very
thrilled we have um Ina swantani here
from uh from Spacey um as a speaker and
Alessandro sorcero from salando and The
Institute of ethical Ai and machine
learning as speakers and there will be a
lot of networking and yeah it's next
week no next month sorry and the 21st of
September so please sign up we already
have like almost 100 people signed up
and we already have the first lightning
talk for the this already which is the
first time ever yeah so very welcome
um and yeah who likes stock waffles
wow very good so Pi data Amsterdam is
coming it's actually next next it's just
a week before the barbecue so uh yeah
it's it's always a great conference
there's also like the first paella
Amsterdam after the corona Break
um so I'll be there and yeah so check it
out and if you want to attend there's a
community voucher just talk to me
um who likes to do now
oh what could this be of course yeah I'm
really happy to announce the we have the
dates for the next Pike on D and Pi data
Berlin and coming in April 22nd next
year save the date it's actually 10
years of Pi data balloon and it actually
um it's 10 years
um yeah 10 years ago there was Euro
python uh Pi data was Berlin was the
first party of Berlin was a satellite
event for Europe which was actually by
the pycon de team and and fun fact it
was my first Euro python ever and yes
and see where he got me
um yeah also
that we have always like a constant call
for speakers so if you have something
you want to present like a lightning
torque or like a a full talk just submit
an idea um yeah it's it's it's it's
always important to the community shares
the expertise with other people's
members in the community or meet up as a
safe space so
um if you it's also like I think a great
opportunity to train for a big
conference talk that's conference is
coming next year as well
um and also like organizers are happy to
Mentor so if you if it's your first talk
just ping us and we can give you some
insights and
we have slido to ask questions
especially for people who join remote
um you can also find the slider link on
the meet up page also
um if you have any questions just
um write them there and now I'm really
happy to introduce Robert over there
Mike's on and with this talk beyond toy
data sets time series forecasting for
real business problems
thank you
foreign
we see that we can't see anything yes
so it worked before right Alexander
[Music]
oh wait I think now
with Thunderball the best
hmm
tankies with pigs
okay so yeah it's perfect nobody touches
anything anymore
all right cool um yeah uh everybody
Welcome in our operator's office first
of all I want to thank you that um it's
a big honor for me giving just talk to
you and telling you something about
um yeah my daily work and working with
time series data time series forecasting
so I'm really I'm really honored giving
you this talk today
um the name of my talk is as you see it
beyond toy data sets um time series
forecasting for real business
um free business problems my name is
Robert haza I'm a physicist studied here
in Heidelberg from bachelor's and
Masters
um during my Master's besides working in
condensed metaphysics I always deep deep
diving into forecasting
um into forecasting models sorry for the
I don't touch anything
um I was sleep diving into a Time series
forecasting a lot
um also I was investigating and studying
back in 2019
um already Transformer algorithms and um
I was implementing my own transformer
based algorithms brought them into
production and I think it was at that
time that when I realized that there is
great potential within those algorithms
namely being Transformer based or being
any kind of deep learning technique and
that we should at able use them as well
next to other other more fundamental
statistical methods or machine learning
methods
um yeah back in University I was then
very very motivated to just use my
knowledge about all this all this
technology and then just go into the
industry and just apply it but then I
brutally experienced two things
in reality in real business problems
like Excel still seems to be the best
best best practice and secondly this
data sets I was working with then in
this three were not as beautiful as they
were in University they were not like
pre-processed for me they had gaps they
had
they had everything but it was not nice
it was not that beautiful so
um especially that last Point motivated
me to give this talk to you today
because I want to emphasize basically
the differences that we that we see in
real world scenarios and also some
Concepts that need to be applied in
order to cope with those rewrite
scenarios and with all the with all
those little
um with all this little
uh traps that you can that you can
basically be being a walk in and
um basically what I want is the goal of
today would be that you understand the
basic concepts the basic ideas of if
you've ever found yourself in the in the
situation of coping with the time series
forecasting problems you do understand
the basic concepts and ideas of it and
you'll be able to avoid those pitfalls
and just turn your use cases into
success story
um
yes so um I think fabian's already said
give us a small outline about projectors
itself for me working as an AI scientist
here what I what I what I um why I see
ours approach as Superior
um is because we don't stop at purely
implementing or deploying machine
learning models itself we don't stop at
the prediction itself we want to use the
predictions and
um and and put some optimization on top
of it in order to not only
do the predictions but also enable and
decision makers decision makers to be
able to to to to to to do optimal
decisions on top of our artificial
intelligence I think sorry for that
um
yes I think it's very important to to to
leverage decision made to to help
decision makers making optimal decisions
within complex environments and this is
what we at barrito strive for
all right
um let's look at our outline first of
all I want to give you uh a brief
introduction
into time series forecasting in general
um afterwards
um
um secondly I want to talk about
um to to go from Toy data sets to re to
real business forms I will explain later
what I mean with toy data sets but I
think this is a very important
distinction we should make here and
third but not last I want to give you
some ideas of how modeling in reward
scenarios does look like what are the
the things the pitfalls that you have to
be aware of in order to turn use case
into success stories and also especially
in the um give you some examples in the
analysis of uh what what what we all
need to what you need to take care of as
well
so first of all
um probably you all know this guy for
our International Spectators okay this
is one of the big German quiz Masters or
show Masters and he's asking you
following question and I want to take I
want you to check out your phone or I
don't know if you have pen and paper
with you and just type in what is the
first and most important step when doing
time series forecasting okay we have
answer a which would be the hyper
parameter tuning so if you want a
machine learning model you need to
optimize it we all know that so
definitely important we are running the
baselines meaning running some some some
some simple models as well next to some
some other models might help you might
doesn't help you I don't know
um C would be used the latest set of the
art models we all read about Transformer
models we read about MLP based models
and multi-layer perception models
um maybe also state
always being up to date can definitely
help you with the results or the uh ask
your activity what am I actually doing
here
so please write down your question I
will reveal in the end what was what's
my right answer at least
okay
um
all right that was good
sorry I just changed my docking station
yes ah this is not right
display settings or what
duplicate slideshow
sorry
does anybody know where to click here
which one yeah
[Music]
yes
almost yes I see it very good
foreign
right
now
okay perfect perfect that is perfect
thank you for
um yeah thanks for being so patient with
my technolicious you know deep Tech is
not always that easy
all right um so um I wanted to give you
a brief overview about what time series
is about actually it's quite easy you
you're basically what you have what
you're doing is you're predicting some
future observations based on your
historical values I mean time series
normally it's not that it's not that
widely spread in it it's not like a
classical machine learning technique or
um like like an area but we see those
time series basically in every company
because every data that is checked over
time can basically in the end be
implemented and formulated as a Time
series problem
where we see the most um the biggest
Leverage is for example in e-commerce um
companies where they sell like they have
a big e-commerce shop and they sell 10
20 000 sometimes one hundred thousand
different products and they need demand
for every single product in order to um
to to make their supply chain
um effective so knowing the time series
the demand in this case up front is a
big Advantage for that for their
business secondly we also see for
example Finance is I mean it's this is
um for example stock stock forecasting
all that stuff with that just let us try
it sometimes more successful sometimes
without any success
um but these are classical classical
areas of Time series forecasting
um let's don't get distracted too much
by the by the whole mathematical
definition all I want to show you is
basically
um that we we do predict some targets
why based on some feature Matrix X we
can therefore also since we predict
multiple targets at the same time we can
basically explain the times with
forecasting as a multivariate regression
problems where you just predict multiple
targets at the same time what is
important is um what kind of features do
you have
um you do have for example the kpi
itself if you want to predict the future
demand you have to take your your
historical demand into account you can
you you have or you can take historical
features into pound meaning it was your
stock field at that point in time or not
there's these important information in
order to predict the demand
um accordingly
also what is important is for example
future information future coverage which
are denoted by by this for example is
there a salespace upcoming what will be
the weather tomorrow in Heidelberg or in
three days in Mannheim these are all
important information that we need to
take into account in order to make this
prediction more accurate
um so now I brought you a really simple
example with which is the air passengers
data set the app passengers data set is
just the data where the air passengers
being tracked how many flights were
taken between the years 1949 and 1961
and uh as you can see this is one of the
data set that is often used for
benchmarking your model so you see if
you read papers in this area you see a
lot of times okay let's Benchmark on on
air passengers there's also other other
typical Benchmark sets like Boston house
prices this is what you read everywhere
in the papers so these time series not
all of them but most but but most of the
times they do have some some some some
simple characteristics that are that we
can fit for for example here and we want
to we want to characterize the trend of
the time series we see there's a clear
Trend there's a clear upwards Trend in
the in this scenario so this is like one
thing that we have that we have to fit
the other part that we have to um that
we have to try to characterize is the
seasonality so we see just before Before
Christmas the air passengers increases
therefore this is the seasonality part
the ultimate goal basically of Time
series forecasting is to identify Trends
seasonality but also the influence of
external information
they are like I said other Benchmark
sets the air passenger said the Boston
house prices
um so this is what I was working off in
Academia and this is what I refer to as
a toy data set it's only one a single
time series not not often super not
often super complex but it has some some
some characteristics that can be fit by
normal
um time series approaches but what we
see in Real Life Is that real life data
sets they're just different beasts
and I mean they sometimes they can they
they are they're kind of dangerous they
can't bite sometimes
um but today I want to give you an idea
of how to cope with them even though
they look like that
okay first of all
um biggest diff one of the biggest
difference is
in these real life time switch data sets
we see tons and tons of multiple
heterogeneous data sets meaning
you can have arbitrary menu data data
sets data points products in a portfolio
with this that can exceed 100 000 of
skus that also they all have to be
predicted separately and when I say
there's a lot of data
there is really a lot a lot a lot of
data
and then there's data everywhere
okay so really
um just imagine we have two million or
maybe 200 000 skus times the historical
part of what two years and on a daily
frequency it's like uh 200 000 times 730
days data points this is what this is a
normal amount that you have to expect
when working with real live data sets
and what we also see is we have a lot of
um data sets for example here data
spikes that are really driven
immensely by external factors so if you
look on the left there is that there are
also data spikes but you can you can
extract them you can characterize them
by the seasonality part by by looking at
historical values here you we know for
example here there was a sales day so we
have time series peaking up within one
or two days and then drastically falling
afterwards again
and this is all being influenced by
external factors so we have to take
external factors into account we have to
find the right models to take them into
account in order to really come up for
for a proper um demand prediction
another one is a cold start problem
cold stuff problem means there are
products time series demand whatever
where we have no to only less historical
data for that
um just imagine you have a product
launch here of a product that you never
sold before in your in your in your in
your shop in your e-commerce uh company
whatsoever but you need to have like a
like a like a um like a picture in your
mind or like a roundabout number of what
will be the demand and just imagine just
imagine you are sitting here on this on
this pink line
and you know only that you sold nothing
until now what do you do
you can imagine it's hard it's hard to
get a proper um prediction for that but
there are techniques
last but not least and we see a lot of
intermittent time series in reward
scenarios intermittent time series A
Time series where it they consist are
mainly for out of zeros there is no
clear seasonality or Trend defined and
the the the the data that you see is
more or less just noise so it's hard to
it's hard to to to to to to to fit any
kind of any kind of
um any kind of seasonality or something
um it's really only that and you have to
cope with that
um since we see these time series a lot
in different different areas I want just
to have a little bit more Deep dive on
the intermittent time series and just to
give you an idea what can't what can be
done with that
um this is also typical for e-commerces
where you have a product portfolio out
of um 200 000 products or let's say 20
000 products and 19 500 products are
being sold almost no it has on a 500
products they drive the whole revenue
and then you have a majority of products
that are actually in a similar manner to
that and that is you need we need to
find ways of coping with that and one
way I want to show you today is the
crosster method
um this is one of the most classical
methods that you can use in order to
model intermittent demand
um there are further advantages but I
just want to give you an idea of what is
possible and then we can maybe have
later on a discussion of what else would
I as also possible in this area so for
the crossed method um sorry here
um I just you know I wrote down in the
bar the the values for the time series
um just for visualization purposes and
then what the customer method does for
example it models this one-time series
separately into two-time series meaning
the first time series denoted here with
the queue just holds the non-zero values
whereas the second time series The a
holds the frequency of how often does do
non-zero values occur in the end these
two more these two these two time series
here are fitted separately within a
exponential smoothing formula so this is
a really simple formula and you you just
get your prediction by dividing
um the the predicted Q value by the
predicted a value for me it's not super
important that you understand every
detail of that they are also further
Advanced methods from the crosstalk
method but just be aware of that there
are techniques if you look at data that
looked like this before they are
techniques to cope with and you should
not naively just throw anything at it
because this will probably fail
okay this is the key message
um all right so we now look at the data
we looked at certain criteria of the
data
so
yeah so let's predict I mean what can
possibly go wrong
I mean every data scientist should last
because actually everything can go wrong
if you if you do if you if you're
handling a data science project like
this but for now we looked at the data
and we now just throw models at our
problem and you know I I introduce
myself as an AI scientist so therefore
as a good AI scientist what I do I do of
course I pick all my neural networks
that I have just throw them at my
problem and I just see what comes out of
that and what could potentially come out
I mean this is a plot that we that we
that we see that we saw sometimes that
we see sometimes you know I have on the
y-axis I have my root mean squared error
and I want to Benchmark my enhance model
because it's like a
super Advanced time series model map
based whatsoever super nice
um the TFT model which is like a
temporal Fusion Transformer it combines
lstm Transformer Network so it's really
really hot
probably everybody knows I know step
so I mean I see here my index model
performs the best it's the most advanced
model so I can just deploy my in its
model
um my work is done for today and I give
it to the customer
right
or what's missing you
does anybody have a clue what's what
could be missing like in order to be
really sure
that this is a good model
it's a real evaluation yeah we'll come
to that in a second yeah
yes right okay I I don't have to teach
you anything today
a baseline correct because having those
results
um just like that it doesn't it doesn't
is tell you anything you could be really
good you could be really bad you could
be mediocre in between somewhere you
don't know
so running a bit um so having for
example what is a really really good
leverage in order to convince customers
from the business value you create is
when your customer does his own
predictions and does its own forecast
and you get the numbers
then if you're lucky enough and you
evaluate his own forecasts it could
maybe look something like this
that's the easiest way if you can show
the customer what he do what he does and
what you do with your models you have
such a such a margin of how you perform
better
um to this is the easiest win to
convince someone that you actually
provide business value for you for your
Solutions
um if you do not have any customer data
any customer forecast running baselines
is your bread and butter like this is
something you have to do before every
machine learning run because right now
looking at this plot here suddenly we
see that our naive bass lines and it
could be various different ways and
statistical baselines whatsoever
they outperform your whole machine
learning fancy stuff
and this is not even that
um this is not even that's unusual that
that something happens like this for
example especially for intermittent time
series we see that statistical models
actually perform quite well with that
and having those bass lines in place is
super super important in order to to set
your results into into perspective and
you just said have a proper analysis and
that's that's totally true
I mean we're talking about data sets
that are super nice having this Global
summary statistics um just looking at
one number in the end it doesn't it
doesn't tell you like the whole story of
the underlying of the underlying
Dynamics looking for example again at
the data distribution
um we see that we have also again some
Pareto pageto optimal situation where
only 20 of products
can hold up to 80 86 percent of the
sales volume and 50 40 of the products
can hold up to 96 of the whole volume
meaning 60 of the products only make up
four percent of your of your sales
volume
ignoring this
uh ignoring the status statistics in
your in your in your in your analysis is
totally will will totally
um you will totally fail by that so for
example one possibly classification is
by saying I analyze my products based on
my volume or I analyze them based on my
variants or I built some some useful
product clusters that that reveal
basically dynamics of the data set and
also help you as a data scientist but
also your customer to understand what
actually his problem is and how your
performance is
and then
um your performance can look something
like this where you see for example oh
wow my my deep learning mode my machine
model does perform very good On A and B
categories but it does really poorly
perform on C categories and this helps
you in order to to
um to yeah to improve your your whole
your whole time series forecasting
engine basically
all right
um so to sum it up
um what is very important what is most
importantly you should always be be
aware of the of your data and your
underlying data distributions and choose
the appropriate algorithms looking at
intermittent problems or Discord start
problems also I didn't talk about that
but this can be very promising you can
provide a mixture of models and combine
the predictions and um and and and give
this as your final prediction we also
see some very positive results there
secondly
um choose some appropriate clusters on
your time series data for your for your
analysis
um which is what is very important here
analyzing your model performance only on
clusters it does not mean to only train
on those clusters like these are two
different things and we should
definitely differentiate here because
training only on certain clusters is not
a good idea you miss a lot of
information there C running baselines
before using any machine learning any
deep learning model before even thinking
about that running your business doing
your homework is most importantly and
without it you're just missing context
and it's hard to convince yourself your
colleagues your customer in the end
right so again coming back to the
initial question
um who did vote for a
H nobody for d
yes
perfect and the ones voting for B you
were right okay yeah nice I mean it's a
highly subjective question you could do
you should check we should check yeah
um it's a highly subjective question but
this is definitely one of the most key
factors that you should do at every
beginning of analysis of use case
yes
um that was my talk I hope some Concepts
got clear to you even though you're not
even highly or you're not even working
at the moment in this field but keeping
the data distribution in mind and also
like some analysis Concepts that you
should definitely be aware of I hope it
helps you um and yeah thank you very
very much for listening and uh yeah I'm
looking forward to the pizza in the chat
with you
thank you
so thanks a lot Robert for the great
talk I think we have a couple of minutes
for questions at this point there are no
questions on slido so if you're looking
remotely and you want to ask a question
please ask your questions on slido but
you can of course also ask your
questions locally here
whom who does have a question
first of all thank you very much for the
explanation I could relate most of the
part because I think I'm doing exactly
same stuff in my job currently
and just wanted to know your view about
how important it is to retrain or model
with the errors which you are having in
actual right so for example we made a
prediction for this month and
then we saw some actual how do you think
that the error which came between our
actual and predicted values make sense
in this kind of scenarios yeah
um I think this is enough right
so uh first of all I think it's hard to
give you like this explicit answer of
how much retraining um you should do I
mean there are certain papers that tell
you okay after four weeks after six
after eight whatsoever I think first and
foremost what is important to always
track and lock your real life
performance so do because
um having only your testing data in
place or your whole outside data in
place it does not give you
um it does not ensure that also your
model will perform like that also in
life so having this in place is the most
important stuff to always be able to
analyze also a retrospective your
results
um in in in in a new real life scenario
I think this is the most important step
that you should do besides that I think
we saw depending on the on the area
depending on the business that after
six to eight weeks we saw in some use
cases some some performance tip so if if
this is like for us somehow some rule of
thumb especially working in high high
Dynamic areas um where you should where
it makes sense to retrain but I think
you will see it if you track it
constantly you will you will see it for
for each business and each data set um
yourself yeah
yeah thank you
do we have more questions
ah
hi uh thank you for your talk uh so just
one question uh you talked about like
the state of the art models uh TFT NH
and XC boost so when it comes to
e-commerce industry uh especially like
Fashion retail uh where the data is very
volatile most of the times and you
hardly have any historical data in many
cases so from your particular experience
uh can you suggest which are the methods
which really work well for what kind of
uh product categories yeah
yep good question
um
so what I so what I what I would say and
what we see is I mean they are there's a
lot to say about that so the most
important most important rule or most
important fact is the the higher your
data set the bigger that your data set
gets
um the more heterogeneous your data set
is so for example we have data sets with
well I'm sometimes I work with data sets
10 20 30 000 groupings but I could take
a relatively small model since the the
data set was not that heterogeneous to
other data sets so there are the data
sets they they had similarity so I
didn't need that capacity of a big model
to really be able to to model all
different time series when we see bigger
data sets more heterogeneous data set
your model just needs capacity of being
able to model
intermittent but also take exogenous
variables into account you know in order
to being able to model influences of
external data all this stuff just means
that they're more complex the problem is
the more data you have the more
heterogeneous your data set gets the
more capacity you need and we see for
example that MLP based and hits
um they're working quite well
um also they're very effective you know
you can iterate a bit more faster I'd
say than with Transformer based methods
because they just need a lot of training
time and you really need to look after
learning rates and all that stuff
um
then it's it's yeah so this is my my
rule of thumb they are eat more Advanced
Techniques sometimes also this one
Global model does not the best job you
need combinations of models depending on
on what data you're actually trying to
predict but yeah
yeah
do we have further questions
yeah thanks for the talk I have a
question about the cost functions that
you use do you also sometimes use more
exotic cost functions with your
customers
with the customers yeah maybe someone is
asking okay rmse doesn't matter to me I
want to make good decisions yeah as
you've also outlined I want to measure
for instance how do those metal models
help me to make better decisions yeah so
um so there's definitely so so first of
all what what we see is that
um the the metrics used to evaluate with
the customer and the loss functions that
you're talking about training our models
um they are not necessarily always the
same
um having a simple metric function for
your customer to be able to explain how
good you are in like in in numbers that
are
um that are also understandable if
you're not like a mathematician um or
something it's very very important
um this has nothing to do with what we
use as s loss functions but I think you
um you were hinting or you were waiting
on another point for example
um loss functions to see um for example
if over predicting the demand is more
costly for their own use cases than for
example under predicting meaning for
example you Overstock okay you have more
cost cost in for example in your for
your warehouse but underpredicting is
like really is really really bad for you
since you lose a lot of sales so that
that hurts even more than just over
predicting and on on the optimization
part I mean Fabian is optimization
expert here under optimization part we
obviously we use more fancy metrics in
order to display our actual value on the
demand prediction side I think from my
experience it's better to use more
simple metrics and to explain
um the the the the character the
behavior of your model by that and not
two fancy metrics I think on
optimization side it's a little it's a
little it's a little different right
look at the coffee bar custom metrics
are really expensive because they
because they're caveats and I was like
if you optimize for them always some
things that you've never thought about
before
okay thank you
all right we now do have a question on
slido asked by Gus and I'll try to
rephrase it or read it do you consider
training time and model explanation
stats and ml models usually trains way
faster than neural networks and also
helps you to understand a little more
the data yes that is a really good
question so obviously
um
yes of course we include training times
um when when when when choosing our
models I mean just just uh just thinking
about it I'm training a statistical
model can take some seconds so you do
not have to think too much about for
example about infrastructure how you
store your models in the end you can
basically it's a trade-off but you can
also say okay I train my stats models
just every time it doesn't matter
um about storing obviously
um for example when you use the neural
networks and it takes much more
infrastructure in order to make those
models work explainability is a very
good topic I mean you have some some
really simple models that are purely
that that that provides some
explainability from the shelf for
example I mean we're talking about
linear linear models obviously it's easy
you're talking about decision trees
where you you not really get less it's
not super expandable but you get at
least some kind of feature importance
and you do not get that from from top of
the Shelf from the neural networks we're
working with that being said there are
also techniques that make your dates
that lets you explain your your model
even better talking about shapley values
or something like that you can for
example combine the sharp values with
your neural networks and then you get at
least induce some kind of explainability
um for us I think performance is highest
prior
um secondly explainability
all right thanks a lot I would say
before we move on we give a warm hand to
Robert
[Applause]
yeah and now locally we'll have pizza it
as a rifle ready
line we will be back at eight o'clock
thank you
he gets to drop okay
all right
so welcome back everyone
I know you're free
we uh everybody seems to enjoy the
conversation so uh a lot sorry for the
interruption but we have late we have um
networking after the lightning talks as
well so uh I'm happy to uh welcome you
all back to the second part of the
Meetup um so we are now the next is
Leon's talk he will talk about lmms for
business with the blockchain after that
we will have free lightning talks and
after that we can continue all the
conversations I just interrupted sorry
and yeah so please give a warm then to
Leon
[Applause]
not mesh
okay again technical difficulties
but now with the mic I hope my HMI works
okay
Cliffhanger there
all right everyone
um happy to be here I'm excited for
today's uh for the today's talk
um first of all thanks for operators for
hosting this event and now it
are you serious
okay it works I'm not touching it I feel
you a robot
um yeah thanks for potatoes for hosting
this event and thanks for pay data for
having me it's actually my first Pi data
conference and then as speaker so it's
an honor to be here and the topic for
today is is Lang chain which is an LM
framework which you can uh like you can
good get the full potential of llms out
of out of llms with LinkedIn and yeah
but before I start I'd like to introduce
myself
um this is me and this is my picture and
here are some facts about me I studied
mechatronics originally
um at hoshulu Mannheim and I focused on
artificial intelligence in my in my
masters
and originally I worked in the CV area
so I did a lot of pedestrian detection
with Lida and radar data and this was
also my Master's thesis and yeah
originally I wanted to to do a PhD
afterwards but I then I I got stuck in
building building stuff with with value
and this is why I don't knocks because I
saw
so great potential in the in the company
and in the e-commerce in the e-commerce
bubble as I say and especially with with
llms which I work nowadays mostly
um yeah and it's a lot of fun it's an
it's an open playground for for AI and
this is why I'm excited about it and
yeah
um some some personal facts about me my
free time I'm a Triumph lead I do a lot
of swimming cycling and running yeah so
far so good about me
okay this is our roadmap for today uh
first I'm going to give a small
introduction uh what Langton is and why
you guys should use it and why you
should play around with it then I'll
present some some features of link chain
which I think give the most value
um for for companies or for your
personal fun or your personal interests
and then I'll provide some example
applications which we use at snog soul
and which I think every company can use
to to leverage llms then I give a short
summary and then we'll have the Q a
all right let's get right into it
um what is link chain and why should you
use it
basically Nang chain is a framework
which makes the work with llms with
large language models way easier so it's
basically you can think about Lang chain
as a connection between the llms and the
outside sources which could be Google
which could be Wikipedia which could be
your own docs which could be like notion
and yeah basically it makes the the
connection between these two parts or
these these two sources way way easier
how does an application including length
train look like you have you would have
a normal front end could be like
streamlit or it could be a normal react
front end which we have at snox and then
you have the Lang chain framework or the
link chain application
um between the the front end and the
large language models and basically
every function in Lang chain
is to to make the
llms more accessible
right then one could say why did I not
simply use the open API and that's
basically a valid question because the
API is just fine you can you can use it
for a simple prompt for simple prompts
and I think every one of you has
prompted GPT before and this is the same
with with the API if you have a simple
input output problem then just use the
the open API but I'm going to
demonstrate in a second where the value
of link chain is with a simple uh with a
simple example and then you'll see why
length chain is is so good and why I'm
so excited about it okay let's switch
okay
can you see that yeah nice okay I've
I've prepared a little uh Jupiter
notebook for for every feature I'm going
to I'm going to present uh in the first
um
what is it called I don't know in the
first cell nice English
um you you have the basic Imports and
then
um
am I in the right I'm not in the right
notebook I'm sorry
um basic Imports like I said and then
this is what you would do for the normal
GPT API or GPT API with a little help
helper function which is called chat and
then you return the response and of
course this is not too complicated and
it works just fine like I said for the
for the simple question tell a joke for
AI scientists it works just fine
and uh this talk is pretty bad so let's
move on
and uh this and in Langton in a nutshell
is uh that is just way less complicated
so you can see you can do the same thing
in just two lines of code so and of
course you could argue okay why does
this provide value but you can imagine
the more complicated the problem gets
the more value Lang chain can give and
this is what I want to demonstrate in
this in this presentation
okay
then let's jump back into the
presentation
you can see it again right yeah
okay
features of length chain
um there are a lot of features
um too many to to handle in this
presentation this is why I want to focus
on prompts and how Langston handles
prompts because I think that's a pretty
good touch point because everyone has
prompted for for GPT and this is a good
entry point I want to talk about chains
agents and Company combinations with
tools and then the vector store
integration of link chain
okay let's start with prompts and uh
yeah like I said for basic prompts just
use the API and but for more complex
prompts or even Dynamic prompts
langstain provides a lot of tool sets
which make the the work just just a lot
easier which I'm gonna demonstrate in
another example which I prepared for
today
let's see
here we go now we go into this now
that's that's the right one okay this is
basically after the the normal Imports
this is basically the same thing which
you did before we Define a prompt and
this time it's in e-commerce because I'm
I'm biased I have to use e-commerce
examples
um
um so here you can see we should write a
product description for Boxer shots from
snox on Amazon and yeah after a short
waiting time and this is what the alarm
provides it's not important that right
not that important right now but this is
where it gets interesting and you can
believe me if you would do a dynamic
prompting with with uh
with standard strings and standard
variables it gets messy pretty fast and
you can see we have four input variables
so we have the text type product brand
and Marketplace and we can dynamically
access these with the template and the
prompt template which we which which we
get from the template and then all we
can do or all we have to do is Define
our text types products it lists Brands
Marketplace and so on and loop through
them I'm not going to run this right now
because it's a
it's expensive and it takes some time
that's the that's a bigger problem right
now and then you can iterate iteratively
just produce a lot of text really fast
and it's not that complicated it's just
these few lines of code and I think
that's pretty amazing and we use that
all the time when building our our tools
um yeah and that's I think a good entry
point on why link chain provides so much
value at least for us
okay
so fast or good let's jump back
to the presentation
here we go
okay next I'm going to talk about chains
I'm only going to talk about LM chains
because I haven't worked with the other
chains there are a lot of chain
variations in in Lang chain but I only
have work with the llm ones and I don't
want to talk here about anything I don't
know so this is why I'm going to stick
to LM chains and a chain is basically a
wrapper around different components of
Lang chain and because there's
um
what does it mean it means basically
that you have you're combining different
LM calls and actions automatically so
I'm going to demonstrate that in another
example
here we go
so imagine a world where you have to
give a high data talk in one week's time
and you have no idea what to talk about
apart from an introduction a structure
which you have gotten from tpd
um definitely didn't happen for me and
uh yeah then I thought I I could build
something with a with the chain which
helps me out on that so I have my basic
structure here and uh
then what I do is I put it into a
template and I provide the template or I
give the template the structure and uh
then I yeah that's what I what I did
before I create an llm I
um created from template and then I
created an llm chain and this LM chain
gets in llm and a prompt template and
the output key is Improvement so
basically what it does it gives me
Improvement uh recommendations for my
structure so this is the first part of
the chain and the second part of the
sequential chain will be another llm and
another template
and another chain also which takes these
Improvement recommendations and puts
them into my structure so it implements
them into the structure and this is how
you can can optimize Concepts really
fast and we at stocks have a tool which
which creates concepts for us with with
Dynamic inputs we which we can choose I
think that's pretty amazing and this is
a light open source version of that and
what I do next
is I I put the two chains into the
sequential chain object and
there then the two chains run after each
other so and then I uh I run them in a
loop and then as you can see it goes
through the iterations and then in the
end I get the the better or better
structure
so
um and you can like extend that I'm
going to talk about backdoor stores in a
minute and you can like I could every
time a new iteration starts I could like
feed another another snippet of the Lang
chain documentation in there to get more
more input into the model and more more
knowledge into the model and so uh uh
refine the the structure even more and
yeah or you can could integrate an agent
which I'm going to talk about as well
okay
then this was everything about chains
back to the presentation
okay yeah Vector Stores
um does everyone know what a vector
store is
I think we're in a good environment for
that okay good
um basically what what Lang chain does
it makes the combined combination of
llms and documents very easy with with
their own Vector stores integration and
this is actually my favorite feature of
Lang chain
um and I'm going to show why because
this is basically the the go to
application and this is I think also the
reason why link chain was founded in the
first place because they wanted to do
stuff like that I'm going to show
another example
jumping bag
okay here we go
Okay so
we have some input which is our our
input data and I'm I'm only going to
show this part of the input which are
basically some some questions our
finance department would ask like that's
our arbitrary questions which our
finance as a department could ask and
this is basically our oh didn't
want to do that sorry
um
yeah and what we do
is we yeah basic here and we we load the
the text oh why doesn't it work love it
okay now it works thank God got nervous
um okay and then we split them into into
chunks and we we embed them like in a
vector embedding and it doesn't work
again
how it works
um I don't know what's wrong believe me
and uh yeah we embed them using the open
AI API and then we load them into a a
vector start using pickle you could use
any Vector storage we use mongodb for
example or you can use pine cone
whatever you like but I think for this
demonstration this pickle dump function
is is just fine
um and then we can of course load it
again create a prompt template like I
like I showed you before
um and uh yeah this is where it gets
interesting basically we we create a
retriever object
um which takes the Other M the chain
type and then the vector storage as a
retriever that's important and then we
can what we can do is we can query the
the vector storage with a similarity
search and uh and over the llm we can
ask the we can ask the llm questions and
it answers based on the knowledge in the
database and this is like uh I think
what provides the most value in line
chain at least for us it does and I
think that's pretty amazing if it would
work why doesn't it work
I don't know I'm sorry it worked this
morning
I'll try one more time
otherwise I'll move on
does not work
sorry guys
okay then I'll move on I'm sorry
okay
um the next thing I want to talk about
um is or our agents and combinations
with tools
um basically what they what agents do is
I've shown you chains and I I remember
what agents do by thinking about chains
that are undetermined so if you if you
have a chain then you you know what to
do next but an agent can make the
decision on what to do next and this is
from my opinion pretty amazing and
basically agents are in in this area
here right
right here and they they make the
decision on when the llm needs
information from an outside Source or
the llm makes the decision on when it
needs information from the outside
source
um and um I'm gonna show another example
I hope it works this time
okay it's uh it's a pretty short one
okay your agents
again the Imports and then all we have
to do is instantiate another model and
we have a tool called math it's it's the
other math and it's basically a a tool
which can do calculations and we
initialize that and then what we do is
we initialize the agent with an llm
and with the agent there are multiple
agents I just use this one here I can
read the documentation if you want to
know everything about the agents it's
not that important right now and then we
ask it how are you and now the
are you serious
oh no it works okay
demonstration error love it okay
moving on
um what the llm should do here is
recognize that this is not a math
question and that it doesn't have to
um to do a calculation and does not have
to to use the tool and it does it
perfectly so it it answers I'm doing
well well thank you so you see how the
agent works and then the next thing is
we ask it what's 100 divided by 25 and
then you see the llm things and it sees
okay I need to calculate this
and it's the action is it uses the math
tool and then it calculates it of course
the alarm could have done it with the
API as well but if you have more complex
calculations or more complex tools like
Google search or there's even a Wolfram
Alpha integration for link chain which
is pretty handy and yeah I just wanted
to make clear how our agent thinks and I
think this example is pretty cool for
that
okay
um
so far about the the features no more
examples today
here we go
oh
okay
I'm going to talk about the example
applications which we use at snox and
which I think are pretty pretty handy
for almost every company which which
sells products or which has data and I
think the most commonly known example is
the personalization which I I've talked
about a little before and it's basically
you have a user on the left side which
has a question like in like in Tech GPT
but the the to the model not only knows
what chat CPT knows but it also knows
what's in your vector database so you
could basically what we did is we we
took our notion for example and we put
it in in the vector storage and then you
do a similarity search
and you can ask it questions about the
company or about anything if you have
the data for it and this is quickly
implemented in in Lang chain I think it
took me like three or four days of
course then you have to do fondant and
stuff but the the decor application is
pretty pretty fast implemented and it
gives a lot of value more value than I
thought because
if you if you take like we are 120
people and you make everyone like two or
three percent faster because they don't
have to go through notion every time
they have to find something out about a
company
um that's that's that's a lot of value
and I think that's a pretty nice and
pretty simple uh application you can
build with uh with Lang chain
okay
the second thing uh I I came up with is
a um like a notification system for
customer reviews so everyone that sells
products could use this so basically
what you have as an input is customer
reviews from
Let It Be Amazon or let it be your your
own portal or let it be like via
letters or whatever and you take oh no
that has wouldn't work because you
that's not digital
big brain here
um okay
um
yeah you you take these customer reviews
and you you put them into the vector
storage like I said before you you embed
them using the the openai API and you
put them into a vector storage and then
what you do you you make some prong
prompts uh on finding out the most
important information you need for for
example here for the product development
team and you summarize it using another
llm which is pretty again pretty basic
but for the for the product development
team it's a huge step because they spent
like
30 of their time are not 30 let it be 20
20 of their time looking at reviews
finding out what the next product should
should make better or what what's the
best feature for our customers which we
definitely should stick to and now they
get a weekly report on what they should
implement or should not Implement in the
next product or what they should
make better with the current product so
I think that's that's pretty cool and
then also with Lang chain this was
pretty pretty easy to to implement
and the last example application which I
have today is a bit more advanced but
um I think it's uh it's again pretty
clear so you you'd have a axle or a CSV
um for example in our use case it's uh
it's an ad report so the performance of
of ads from Facebook for example and you
put them into a data frame pandas data
frame and you have rules for optimizing
ads so we have some
some rules internally how our
Performance Marketing team optimizes ads
and this could be in any channel and
then what we do is we put them into
length chain we initialize a pandas data
frame agent which is basically an agent
working with with data frames and there
you can get a lot of information out of
these data frames and what we do is we
extract the kpis like our kpis which we
which you want to track out of the out
of the CSV and then we use a our rule
embeddings which we put into a vector
storage combined with a chain for for
optimization recommendations
so you get like
um
um when you combine these three things
like the kpis the optimization
recommendations and the rule embeddings
in an llm and you can get action
recommendations so you can like have the
for example uh
make the the ad spend higher on this
product or something like that and then
we have our users
or our performance marketers look over
that and then they they submit it or
they decline it and then we can directly
upload the updated
the updated parameters to to our ad
portal which is again this was a bit
more work than the other two but I think
it's still pretty simple and of course
there's this human in the loop so it's
not automated because it's for us it was
not not possible to do not or for me at
that time because I was alone back then
um yeah but I think it's a pretty pretty
nice thing okay
I'm coming to to the summary
um first I said that the length chain is
a framework which makes the work with
with LMS way easier the prom templates
make Dynamic prompts uh easier for you
and I talked about chains and uh yeah I
told you that it's they are a wrapper
and you can like add them together and
make like these these chains of of
actions and llm course
I talked about how line chain can
has its own integration with Vector
storages and how you can leverage that
to
for example build an uh building a chat
board and I also talked about how you
can use agents for for decision making
in an LM or like decision making on when
to call different tools and use Link
Chain as a connection to to outside
tools
um out between the alarms and outside
tools if you can say so okay and I
showed you a few use cases but uh
believe me there's a lot more and I
encourage you to to try out Lang chain
and and work with it because firstly
it's it's a lot of fun and secondly it's
it gives you a lot of or many benefits
for you and I think also for your
company
all right thank you that's it from me
[Applause]
all right we now have time for a couple
of questions
um maybe it would be a good idea to
start by switching on the lights
uh I think that looks like a switch
awesome
hi there a lot of people
all right are there any questions in the
room
yes
and just a quick question about this
nearest neighbor approach uh wouldn't
that create a bias towards like
individuals that that don't have a
neighbor because they're they're kind of
individual opinion someone says oh this
product is crap because of X so it would
cluster all the similar opinions and the
to be honest I can't tell you anything
about it because it's
it's implemented in in the in the
election I believe
use it I'm sorry yeah no no it's just
just a hunch I I wouldn't maybe you
couldn't talk to the to the founders or
you can contribute and challenge it
yeah no I don't know if it's just a
hypothesis it could be completely wrong
on my side too yeah never thought about
it I'm sorry
all right are there any more questions
um so do you only lose length chain and
the possibilities in there or did you
also think about like combining um an
llm maybe for some other classical
method for example using llm for feature
engineering and then use the features
for a classical machine learning model
later on or maybe come basically would
be maybe the same thing but to have a
custom tool for length chain so not only
the Wikipedia tool or calculator tool
that is already provided
can you can build custom tools there is
a class for that and we're definitely
planning on using that
I haven't have not played around with
that because uh yeah I started at smokes
like four and a half months ago and now
at the moment I work on the on the quick
wins and this is with with text and the
the campaigns and all the I say standard
llm stuff but my heart like I said I
come from from CV and standard machine
learning and I I spend a lot of time
with pytorch and I I say I I missed that
a bit so definitely planning on on
working on that in the future but
haven't haven't tried it out yet
all right so to our remote viewers there
are no questions on slido yet if you are
a fast hacker then maybe I can get one
more in
uh yeah what was the craziest thing
um this stuff did what you perhaps
didn't expect uh purpose why I'm asking
like I think when one employee that also
used such an agent and
the agent because I mean it basically
writes code as well just deleted the
whole folder with all the stuff inside
and it was not revertible so
um what what did you experience there
already I I wrote an integration for our
Amazon API
and I thought I deleted all our PPC
campaigns which is
yeah for for those of you who don't know
Amazon it's a lot of money
um so that was a shock but I I only like
moved them into a separate folder so
that's what the agent did and at this at
this moment I was like okay I get a new
account and I make like a test area and
I think that comes close to the craziest
thing that an agent has done for me so
take care of you when you're working
with agents so
thank you
any more questions in the room
so you talked about these tools and then
the agent would choose depending on the
input like okay now I need to use the
math part can it use multiple Tools in
one query like maybe you ask it like
uh currency conversion question with
math could it like check okay I need to
use math calculate and then ask for like
the Forex
yes exchange rate the the input for the
tools is a list so you can you can give
it multiple tools but sometimes if you
have too many tools then it gets
confused on which tool to use so it's if
you have a clear vision of your
application it's better so you you could
think like okay I'm going to put all the
tools in there why not but
um like if you have a clear vision of
your tool then only use the the tools
you know you you will use but because
otherwise it gets confusing it then it
sometimes doesn't use a tool when it
should use it and
that's basically best practice there
any further questions
this is your last chance
but it's nice to see you guys there
sorry about the lights but then let's
move on to the lightning talks
sorry
[Applause]
all right
um
I have to update my slides first
um because there's
um
something came up
oh yeah
just
all right so let me
let me so okay why do I stop with this
because uh actually thanks for listening
uh we just have 100 members which is
great
so
um next answer that's right
so here okay uh now we come to the
lightning talks or I don't see anything
on the screen but I have all lightning
talks prepared so I would like to
lightning talk speakers to come line up
here who does know what a lightning talk
is
oh this is decent crowd yeah so let me
explain lightning talk is you have five
minutes and you can basically say
anything appropriate in that so it can
be yeah that's the best way to phrase it
so it can be something fun it can be an
experience it can give basically
anything but there's a hard five minute
limit there's no questions and we're
going I'm going to take the time from
the lightning talk and if you see me
make this that's like 30 seconds before
the lightning talks end we start doing
this signaling the speaker come on speak
up there's like 30 seconds left and then
the five minutes is just stop it with
the big Applause no matter what so
that's the challenge that's very scary
no I'm I'm totally I'm I'm confident you
will manage but um maybe
let me
make things a little bit easier for you
all because the lightning talks are all
on this
machine and I think it's easier if we
just share the screen
um
that's just like
sync
so and now I think everything is way
easier now because you see the same so
yeah perfect please welcome back
[Applause]
yeah so I'm first I want to apologize
because as you can see I'm a services
that is currently turning into data
scientist so probably there is too much
physics in this book and not enough data
science for your place but well I wish
my best to to still make it present for
you
so the idea is to use this knee to
detect those poweramps of the Milky Way
and you can see on the top left photo
for instance at the beautiful guys in
those power arms and well it's easy when
you have a photo
is a bit inclined it's become very much
more difficult to to identify those
power arms and something like that and
it can even be that you have a spiral
galaxy is not really well defines power
arms and then
do you have not sure what you would do
in that case and in the Milky Way which
is also a spiral galaxy this is what you
see because since we are in the Milky
Way when we don't have several photos
so
so we have to do it with well what we
can do but clip this on the microphone
perfect uh well we cannot identify those
power arms from from the outside so it's
much more complicated actually in our
case
so the IDS while you use what you have
that is coordinates for four stars or
whatever objects you use and distances
and you are kind of bound to Young
objects because otherwise they move from
their birthplace and then they evolve
away from those power arms and also the
spiral arms evolve with time so you you
need to use young objects
and people have done that with mazes so
from the acronym you can guess that it's
an extension of lasers but except that
the emitting is a microwave
and you find those in uh around
youngster objects that's basically Stars
informing so those are a few Mega years
and we know something like 200 in the
Milky Way and this these people read it
I'll have me I've made this model of
spiral arms based on the detection of
these measures and what I did is using
another kind of tracers for which you
also get good distances that are the
safe AIDs that are presetting stars
uh they are a bit older so there is a
chance that they already drifted away
from their from their birthplace but on
the other hand we know something like
more than 3000 in the Milky Way which in
principle helps us to to
properly locate those power arms and you
can see here on the distribution in in
specific direction that the the
distribution of the sephids that speaks
that are the black the black the black
curves that matches quite well with with
the power arm models of read from
measure so probably it's a good tool to
to also
identify those poweramps and I will skip
some details because I guess I have no
time so here are the cephades located
here and uh just uh very quickly you can
see that there are some areas from here
it's not very easy to see but you see
some blank areas in the in this in here
it's just probably at the at the bottom
of this like
cone structures there is a big cloud
that prevents from seeing what's behind
and then we we don't detect the stars in
this region and that will have an
importance later
so well if we talk about spirals uh we
start with let's say the logite mix pi
over and if you if you try to make it a
bit easier you go in a slightly
different space where you expect to have
linear features in the in Theta and
logarithm of value of space where radius
0 R is a distance from the galactic
center
and uh Theta is just the angle you have
a you start somewhere you have a
reference and you turn around the Milky
Way and then you define an angle that
way and then the ID is well you you try
to use Disney which is a
dimension in the dimension native
addiction algorithm to try to identify
groups of cephades hoping it will do
better than and especially not by us
like a human would be
and then so that's what I did and only
using two Dimensions the coordinates and
that's what it looks in the top left in
the Disney space and then in the Disney
space it will be completely gray and
then I use hdb scan which is a cluster
image algorithm to identify these groups
without human biases and some of them
are just bogus some are real groups
hopefully and when you return to the no
the the let's say a normal space the
original space you fight quite some
linear features that you expected and
also again these bogus like the orange
or the pale blue here those are so I
guess I have no time to explain why but
we can chat later
uh and then if you return and then says
your original coordinates and you you
already see features that look like
Spiral arms and then you can on this
linear plate you can do a linear fit
and then you obtain this like olives
um
segments on the spiral arms they fit
quite well with other methods except
this one which was probably completely
wrong
and maybe the good thing is that you
detect new features for instance this
one that has not been seen by any others
so I think it's a pretty uh pretty uh I
was actually positively impressed by the
results I'm not stressed
thank you so I had to cut a lot but we
can chat later thanks a lot
oh sorry okay yes
I don't see what I'm doing so okay very
stressful
okay so
um
foreign
all right yeah thanks for having me
um I'm gonna talk about the idea of
developing an ni based business data
analyst using open AI function calling
so before I go into function calling I
actually first want to address the
question what about code interpreter as
this is currently getting a lot of hype
and so for example if you look on
YouTube there's quite some heavy claims
there that code interpreter is going to
be the end of data analysts right
so I thought all right then looks like I
have to give this a try myself so I
created a simplified version of a data
set I found on kaggle and this data set
actually tracks the page loads and the
unique visitors for each day
and then uploaded this to the CSV to
code interpreter and ask it to plot the
number of unique visitors per year
and so code interpreter then loaded and
inspected the CSV and afterwards it
generated python code it aggregated the
unique Visitors by year and then it
produced a motherboard lip chart all
right so this might look nice overall
but there's a big problem here
the correct answer would have been this
question cannot be answered using the
data set as unique visitors is a
non-editive metric this sounds very
technical what I mean by that is you
know if a user actually visited the
website each day in the year this would
result in this user would have
encountered 365 times in this chart here
so the results are complete
overestimation actually
and so overall I'm not very concerned
that code interpreter is going to
replace data analysts anytime soon
I think it's a tool that can greatly
improves the productivity of anybody
that can cope with python but I don't
think it's something that you want to
directly expose to like non-technical
business users
and this brings me to what I actually
want to talk about which is function
calling so imagine that we had have a
comprehensive retail data set we've
talked about retail before how could we
develop a data analyst chatbot that can
answer a query like the one shown here
using function calling that's like the
setup right and for this we would first
create a system prompt and here I'm
showing a very simplified example that
states you're an expert in data
analytics use the provided functions to
answer the user question you're working
with the following data set and then
here I just concatenate the first five
rows of the data set in markdown format
to give it some context
and next we have to describe basically
the functions that the GPT model should
use for example we can specify a
function filter and aggregate
which takes a list of Dimensions that
should be aggregated and a dictionary of
filters that should be previously like
before it applied on the data set
and then we can also specify other
functions such as
at blood times use function which takes
in a metric and produces a figure for
example a plotly plot
and um we can then iteratively make this
more complex you know we could add a lot
more functions here for example
something like uh plot forecast or maybe
even a function that would identify
anomalies or maybe even run SQL queries
and so the important part to understand
here is that TBT will act like as an
agent and will only return the function
name and the arguments that it wants us
to call but we actually have to
implement these functions ourselves and
then actually call them when it wants us
to call the functions
and so
um
to make this more clear I'm going to
show one example in the action diagram
so first as mentioned we have the system
prompt so we sent the system prompt the
user prompt and the function
specifications to the GPT model
and in this case it would return the
filter and aggregate function name with
the arguments year month and so on the S
dimensions and a filter for City equals
Heidelberg so given the query it thinks
okay this would be the best function to
you know fulfill this query and so we
will then execute this function locally
so basically in the in our analyst and
then we send a next request with the
full conversation history where we also
include a markdown sample of the
aggregated data frame and the model then
reasons that the next function that
should be called is this plot time
series function with the metric sales
and so again we would run this function
locally and then finally we would show
the generated figure in the chat window
so this is like the high level idea of
how function calling can be used to
basically develop custom agents that can
in this actually use KCA act as kind of
a data analyst
and so I think overall
um this is kind of the most promising
Approach at the moment especially
regarding production Readiness for
developing such a tool because it has
several advantages you have full control
over the generated plots you can
incorporate all kinds of guardrails uh
you can you know Implement integration
tests all types of stuff but of course
it's not end to end AI you have to
develop these functions yourself that's
kind of the downside here and then yeah
we're hiring
[Applause]
like that
song okay okay
just took a browser service
all good
yeah
okay awesome all right hey everyone uh
nice to be here my name is Tim bonnerman
I work at IBM research and I'm here to
talk about open source science
open source science is a new num Focus
initiative that was launched last July
we are so to speak cousin of Pi data if
you look at the family tree
um
the goal behind open source science is
to accelerate scientific research and
Discovery by improving the ways open
source software gets done in science so
unlike the Enterprise or private sector
open source or research software and
open source in science has to struggle
with a lot of different challenges
anything from a lack of consistent
onboarding for students all the way up
to
policy settings that prevent open source
from from thriving
we hope to accomplish that by connecting
scientists and open source developers
and other stakeholders in interest
groups we currently focus on chemistry
Material Science Life Science and
Healthcare and climate and
sustainability
and we hope that people will
share best practices and identify common
pain points and eventually move towards
solving some of those issues
um
we are
open for anyone to join who here show of
hands is involved in science somehow
broadly speaking
and
and any one of these people does
software development
keep your hands up okay so we're looking
to connect
you with your peers
um what you can do is
you can follow us
we've been busy setting up our
infrastructure we have a medium as you
can see we have a newsletter oops see
that's not good that's why somebody
recently said we have to move off of
medium because it's not open source
but you can you can do us a favor if you
if this is interesting to you you can
follow us on medium LinkedIn and other
uh channels you can also uh check out
one of the upcoming interest group
meetings these groups meet on a monthly
basis
um and uh
that's pretty much it's under five
minutes so just wanted to make you aware
um I actually have to run after this I'm
meeting somebody else in uh in in
Heidelberg but um anyone going to
Amsterdam for pi data
besides Alexander
okay anyway but I hope to be back
um I'm actually gonna be spending some
time here in uh I'm normally based in
California I'm going to be spending some
time in Germany this coming School Year
and hope to be doing some events with
maybe some of the other Pi data meetups
maybe including paida Southwest
um and uh
see if we can get some good connections
going here
that's it thank you
all right wonderful so
fix this here all right okay so let's
um
let's go there's no watch History there
right so I'm lucky I'm kidding uh so
where's the slot where are the slides so
the slides have the severe no the slides
are here
right so we had three great lightning
talks thanks a lot for contributing to
them uh okay we don't have slido yet so
oh I have to move a bit forward here
okay yes this is important so yes
mentioned before call for speakers some
people approached me tonight so we will
have some talks right in the future
where yes great talk coming up already
lightning talk it's also kind of uh
here right great so uh it's important so
I expect we almost have every month a
meeting come meet up coming up now so we
need content we share your knowledge
prepare prepare for the 2024 conferences
so I think
having a talk at the Meetup is really
great to to prepare and improve for a
larger conference
um and yeah and we're happy to help
um it's also your turn give us feedback
um
hosts and sponsors rate this event on
Meetup
um if how you like it you can reach out
on social media with um on on Twitter or
now called ax or whatever it is will
people ever stop using you calling it
Twitter right that's a big question uh
so
um let me turn off the timer uh so you
can also send an email just to pythonix
victim or reach out on LinkedIn to my my
profile
um and yeah and
we've covered that already and yeah
thank you for being part of pilata
Heidelberg today and we continue with
networking and we say goodbye to the
viewers from on YouTube there were quite
a few on average there were like 40 50
people watching actually somewhere in
the world which is not too bad so we
hope to welcome you back as well soon
all right thank you bye-bye